We are on number 11.
Sonia customized her bicycle by
exchanging the front wheel
for a wheel that had 1/2 the
diameter of the back wheel.
So this'll be a weird
looking bicycle.
We're going to have a small
wheel in front, and then--
let's see if I can
draw a bicycle.
Oh, it looks like it.
I don't know.
Then you have a huge wheel
in the back, right?
Because the diameter of this
wheel is 1/2 of the diameter
of that wheel.
Now when Sonia rides the
bicycle, how many revolutions
does the front wheel
make for each
revolution of the back wheel?
All right.
When you do this problem, how
many revolutions does the
front wheel make for each
revolution of the back wheel?
And let me just make sure it
says that the front wheel has
1.2 the diameter of
the back wheel.
So let me ask you a question.
If the back wheel goes
around-- well, that's
essentially what it
was just asking.
Let's make up numbers.
Let's say that the back wheel's
diameter-- or let's
say it's radius.
Let's say the back wheel
has a radius of 2.
So then, what's its
circumference?
Its circumference, for the back
wheel, would be 2 pi r.
So it would be, 2 times
pi times 2, which is
equal to 4 pi, right?
The circumference of this has
1/2 the diameter, so it would
also have 1/2 the radius.
So the circumference will
just be 2 pi r,
which would be 2 pi.
So this one, if you have 1/2
the diameter, you also have
1/2 the circumference.
And so when this wheel does 1
revolution, how far has the
bicycle traveled, assuming
the wheel
hasn't skidded or anything?
Well, when this back wheel does
1 revolution, the bicycle
would have traveled 4 pi,
whatever our units.
4 pi feet, if that's
our units, right?
So if the bicycle's traveled
the 4 pi units.
It's going to travel 4 pi units
on the front of the
bicycle as well.
So if we've traveled 4 pi units,
how many times does
this wheel have to turn around
to travel 4 pi units?
Well, in one revolution,
this wheel, it's 2 pi.
So this wheel actually has
to turn around twice.
It turns around twice
for every 1
revolution of the big wheel.
Hopefully that makes sense.
You just realize that 1
revolution of the big wheel is
going to be twice the
circumference
of the front wheel.
And so the front wheel has to
turn around twice when the
bike goes over that
same distance.
So the answer to their
question is, how many
revolutions does the front wheel
make for each revolution
of the back wheel?
Well, the answer is, C.
That looks like an E, but
the answer is C, 2.
Problem number 12.
All right.
A list of numbers contains
p positive
and n negative numbers.
So p pos, n negative.
If a number is picked at random
from the list, the
probability that the number
is positive is 3/5.
What is the value of n/p?
OK, so the probability of
getting a positive is 3/5.
So what is the probability
of getting a positive?
Our probability of getting
a positive is going
to be equal to p/n?
That's the probability of the
number of positive numbers we
have over the total numbers
we have, right?
That's the probability
of getting a
positive number, right?
If this was red marbles and blue
marbles, the probability
of getting a red marble would be
the number of red over the
total number of marbles,
right?
So similar here.
It's the number of
positive numbers
over the total numbers.
And the total numbers are the
positive numbers plus the
negative numbers.
And now, they are asking us for
what is the value-- Well
OK, I just want to make sure
I'm doing it right.
If the number is picked at
random from the list, the
probability that the number is
positive-- right, this is the
probability that's positive
is 3/5-- what is
the value of n/p?
So now I'll solve for n/p.
So we could cross multiply
here, right?
So we could say 5p is equal
to 3 times this, is
equal to 3p plus 3n.
I just cross multiplied.
And then, let's see, subtract
p from both sides.
You get 2p is equal to 3n.
And we want to figure
out n/p, right?
So let's divide both
sides by p.
So you get 2 is equal to 3n/p.
And let's divide both
sides by 3.
And you get 2/3 is
equal to n/p.
And we are done.
n/p is equal to 2/3,
which is choice C.
Wasn't too bad.
Problem 13.
Clear image, invert colors.
And I will do it in
this tacky green.
Problem 13.
The total daily cost, c, in
dollars, of producing x units
of a certain product is
given by the function.
All right, we've got a cost
function right here. c of x is
equal to 600x minus
200 over x plus k.
And they're telling us
k is a constant.
And x is less than,
or equal to, 100.
Fair enough.
If 20 units were produced
yesterday for a total cost of
$640, what is the value of k?
So 20 units.
So they're essentially saying
that c of 20, the cost of
producing 20 units,
is equal to $640.
So we can just use this
information to
now solve for k.
So c of 20 is going to be
equal-- put in 20 to this
equation-- so it's 600
times 20 minus 200.
All of that over 20, right?
C of 20, right?
All of that over 20.
Plus k.
I can't forget the plus k-- plus
k is equal to-- we know
that equals to 640, right?
And what is this equal to?
Well, we actually don't even
have to multiply it, right?
Because this is 600 times 20.
And what's 200?
200 is 10 times 20, right?
So you can divide the top
and the bottom by 20.
So you have 20, 20, 20.
So you're just left with 600.
I mean, you could multiply it
out if you don't understand
what I just did.
But you get 600 minus 10
plus k is equal to 640.
So you get 590 plus
k is equal to 640.
Subtract 590 from both sides.
You get k is equal to 50.
And that is choice B.
So you really just have
to substitute the x
into our cost function.
And then set that
equal to $640.
And you've solved for k.
Problem 14.
For how many ordered pairs of
positive integers x, y is 2x
plus 3y less than 6?
So these are positive
integers, right?
We could figure them out.
The 0, we can't use 0.
If x is 1, what can y equal?
So then we have 2 plus
3y is less than 6.
This is a case of
x is equal to 1.
So then we'd have 3y
is less than 4.
So we'd have y would have
to be less than 4/3.
So the only situation where y
is less than 4/3 is y would
have to be 1, right?
Because that's the
only positive
integer less than 4/3.
If x is 2, then we have
4 plus 3y, right?
2 times 2 is less than 6.
And so you have 3y
is less than 2.
y is less than 2/3.
Well, I don't see any positive
integers that
are less than 2/3.
So x can't even be equal
to 2, right?
So neither of these numbers
can get any
bigger than 1 or 1.
So there's only 1 ordered pair
of positive integers that--
positive integers, and that's
the trick-- that satisfy this
equation, 1 and 1.
And we know, because
immediately, when we just
raise one of them above 2, we
get above 6, no matter what.
We can't find a positive integer
that satisfies it.
So that's it.
It's just choice A.
Not too bad.
And I will see you in
the next video.